si diceva che si misura ok non a te devo
preparare l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi dio sono fa vj lei e
margherita che giusto oggi che cosa
volevo fare volevo fare avete presente
trivi a quiz è ormai che ho scassato le
balle così come io ho fatto tre via quiz
molto spesso quindi ho fatto anche qui
su di me l'ultima volta il quiz che ho
fatto l'ho fatto fare a giorgio che un
mio amico
dovresti spuntare che idiota l'ultima
volta ho fatto fare un mio quiz a lui
che che ha non ha saputo rispondere un
cazzo oggi sono qui per provare a far
fare un test su dimette a lei che mi
segue e vediamo se stavolta non facciamo
una figura che però vanta fini carica
guarda che non devi fare con lui ha
sbagliato tutto ha sbagliato tutto
quello che dovrà sbagliare
credo di essere abbastanza informata sei
abbastanza informata carica la ragazza
già facciamo iniziamo io ti do il
proprio il mio telefono fai tu ti si
apre una domanda a casa gli piace fare
nel tempo libero di segnare sono ha
rilanciato donare video ti piace anche
uscire con gli amici lo spero con quel
deficiente non arrecano sei mio amico
lui no basta uscita al video la prossima
volta lo facciamo fare a lui lui e non
faccio io vinco lui è l'unico che si
vabbè dai questa perdona prossima la
prima tela perdono di allenamento in
quale parte fa visioni è andato a più
volte questa normale non vale margherita
ma quando ha fatto la demo di outlast 2
non lo so neanche questo non lo so
neanche allora 2007 ci dà una mano e 16
sicuro era sbagliato io lo sapevo ha
sbagliato letta ha sempre fatto video da
solo si ma prima si chiamava in modo
diverso sino primari 3 prima era mentre
tu nichi pozze giorgio devi andare a
casa cosa sapete bravo un [ __ ] genio
guarda quanto inutile questa persona ci
abbiamo messo un'ora e mezza per mettere
il cavalletto per permettere la macchina
fotografica e lui in un momento di
rabbia lo voltaggio lui come un pirla un
[ __ ] fenomeno rai al next one dove la
si è vista questa è questo e un
photoshop a dio si copertina di gq
e incredibile anche tu sei promossa dal
punto di vista fa vice city 6 promossa
quante volte ha fatto da sabbi vanin già
all'inzio di allora addio
io non titolati semi cavarsela quindi se
sbagli sbagli ore da facce dalla
tensione 52 non è impossibile una per lo
speciale è un'altra mi ricordo che mi fa
chi sta arrampicando sugli specchi per
la scapola che è rosa vedi che era
semplice mai sbagliata no va bene una
scatola giapponese come la vederci
gialla sentito
sono i cinesi giapponesi sono cinesi i
cinesi già i cinesi il cinema sta
lanciarmi cose l'hai vista però sì che
l'ha vista ovvio 3
che culo non la sapevo lo sapevo neanche
io e la 2 ae avuto culo è
qual è il suo primo vlog storia è questa
storia che i baldi primo blog che dj da
sapere
incredibile ma mi ricordavo domanda che
si pone sempre ai botti a hai visto
aggregato sentire vieni tu ne azzecca
troppa devi sbagliarne almeno 19 i
giochi momento di difficoltà è in che
pisodio fa vigilia è più il si trova
pokémon go società aspetta prego salvato
dall imbarazzo per net sicuro 1.160
metri che bergodi schiacciato jolo
porcate fatte non gli darei che tocca a
te non chiusi a caso quale musica
ascolta me no ma se uno che ascolta
musica country nome di martin garics e
slide line siamo andati a tomorrowland
con lui facciamo è un'altra non vale
così come fa come li fai video
pantaloncini e maglietta mutande e
maglietta nudi è un po inganni e poi
cestistico mutante non mutande mutante
mutanti votate
tant'è vero fa civile unix me io faccio
i video con gli alieni vieni giochi
chiamiamo un passante a farla e non è
possibile a sanpa stante vendi passante
a caso venga ben di qua e rispondo a
questa domanda cosa sui fornelli
io io io cosa sui fornelli io che si
sono fatti già conosceva vj e dj cosa
sui fornelli con dj procede andavo
sensate camera andava grazie grazie
signor passante al 33 e ti consiglio di
fila e ti considero 8 fan ma se mi
capita mica semplice episodi era con
questa è una mancano due ragazzi voglio
e lascia pure è certo era la domanda si
pokemon cosa c'entro io
sarà un bonus bandai l'ultima e 6
toccando nel video evitato di instagram
di 2 milioni di iscritti che canzone
ciao luna non ne ho la più pallida idea
ma io non sono un mio fan
nella prossima questa non fare anche
questa palette scartiamo quest'anno
l'altro manco io l'ultima e poi non
scartiamo più se esce brutta cazzi tua
quanti tatuaggi afa vicini a questo
questo grave sa anche dove grazie mille
di aver partecipato cara è stata affatto
una sfida bella la puoi smettere di fare
cose io volevo fare un test e tranquillo
niente non giorni c'è stato verso p
passante è stato bravo l'unica persona
decente quante volte famiglia che ha
fatto un vino insieme a un altro
youtuber la sai 57 no capello non ho
idea giro 7 non era fra me non era se
risulti qual è il titolo dell'episodio
107 di happy wheels e ti potrei stupire
da casa perché tu lo sai mai stai rigori
acrobatici voli acrobatici che culo che
lula che culo incredibile va bè ragazzi
direi che basta perché basta è stato
alquanto strano fare questo video
parecchio strano spero che il video vi
sembra venite tutti a questo punto
passante venga proposta l'ultima a tutti
quanti dai ci serve e quando è stato il
raduno a bergano dell'antegnate shopping
center c'eri anche tu o se la sapete
come facciamo aprile mondo
qualcosa però il gatto ha fatto 100 mila
light per questa roba è come fatto
sapere ragazzi io vi ringrazio verrà
visto questo video come ringrazio anche
a larghe per aver partecipato alla larga
spero che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi mi
piace un commento non mi piace
dovete continuare a tenere ci vediamo
subito dopo il telecomando
cos'è sta roba da ragazzi
ricchini
mentre molti immobili
[Musica]